[Music]
which is very much back twists and turns
and dance and drama and scandal only et
was invited on set of hit the floor as
the highly anticipated series kicks off
filming season 4 for its new network ve
T here's an inside look at all the drama
and super sexy dance moves ahead of the
Summer 2018 season premiere one new
devil girl dancer might look familiar
so yeah bringing it back let's go hold
better it says you know bring it back
with you Tiana Taylor joins the cast as
London what can you tease about your
character so far um actually London is
really just you know coming up from
we're coming back from like a big
scandal you know so she's kind of just
finding her way and in finding herself
again you know so uh she's not a villain
just a person you know hitting you know
rock bottom you know and building
themselves back up she is our version of
kind of Hester Prynne like Scarlet
Letter like someone who has been through
hell you just get the raw with her and
you just get to the emotion you get to
the feeling and her dancing is
ridiculous
I think that she's gonna have like this
like a new fan base we're gonna have on
the show and I think her character is
gonna bring a whole nother vibe and the
fade star isn't the only newcomer on set
I think we're gonna see a breath of
fresh air from this character he's a
rookies he's very innocent and I think
we're gonna pax is gonna be really
allowed the audience to see this
seductive and sultry crazy world from an
innocent and it's not Eve is somebody
who works for the league and she has
ties to the devils and when we meet her
the Devils are kind of going through a
transition period
my character Jaime's really driven she's
very determined she's gonna get on the
squad and she is trying to be the queen
bee I loved see but our characters do
have a little bit of in there we want to
say too much is how do I say I also it
takes you Derek to be my husband so it's
in with the new and out with some of the
original cast Asha and zero won't be
back for Season four leaving some
questions in the air what's going on
with Derek's relationship what's going
with June's relationship and that's
really one of the things that fans are
gonna have to tune in for cuz it's
dramatic I think the likelihood that
we'll see stuff get messy is probably
pretty high are we going to address this
off the top I generally don't like to
make fans wait a long time for bombs
like I think a lot of shows will sort of
milk it and buy the season finale then
you've got I'm like that's just the half
way through whoop there it is first way
to the episode
[Music]